is really going strong and there are so
many new openings you look at the upper
west side I mean it is as if a new
country has been annexed to New York
City wow there's a whole country here
there's places to what restaurants and
are people who will eaten them and you
know they're like 10 really great new
restaurants have opened the down turn I
think we'll make em some restaurants
adjust their menus I think that in New
York City that going out culture is so
ingrained in our blood we will not stop
going out we just don't we might not get
the caipirinha we might skip dessert we
might be really grateful that small
plates have taken over you know eighty
percent of the restaurants so you'd have
two small small plates still have a
great night out and you know leave the
restaurant feeling good about yourself
something we might adjust how the order
but you're so not stopping point out